did you know that around the world  concrete is considered one of the  cheapest and quickest forms of  construction yet in australia it's  considered one of the most expensive and  one of the most luxurious products there  is a very simple reason for this and it  is extremely justifiable the australian  government has huge laws and regulations  in the construction industry making sure  that anything that goes up is  structurally sound so if you're going to  put up a concrete roof or a concrete  wall you're going to have to have  mountains and mountains worth of steel  and reinforcement in that concrete to  make sure it stands the test of time  whereas in other countries these  regulations are so much more relaxed and  a simple earthquake a simple movement in  the ground or just some poor  calculations by somebody could result in  that building collapsing in a matter of  seconds